I'm very proud of my country and that's
why I always will see for an opportunity
and also live to give back anything
possible to my country and serve my
people hi my name is Ramesh Ito mala I'm
an internal medicine resident at saint
vincent chai tea I came from Cleveland
to India on a mission called medical
yatra by translate that in English is a
pilgrimage
I have seen how difficult it is for
certain patients to get to a hospital
when they are sick and very surprised
that they're living that such pain and
they'd have never gone to a doctor I
thought that this is a wonderful
opportunity that I can take back to my
country and serve my people with the
knowledge and the walking skills that I
got from the training that I had got in
u.s.